[Música]
la generación joven de Irán está en el
corazón de las protestas contra el
régimen que se han extendido por todo el
país pero también son Víctimas de una
fuerte represión Durante los recientes
disturbios las fuerzas de seguridad
iraníes mataron al menos a 34 jóvenes y
adolescentes sin embargo Esta generación
Sigue desafiando a las autoridades
protestando contra la República islámica
conservadora y sus dirigentes
hablamos con una profesora iraní no
escucharán su voz para resguardar su
seguridad y transcribimos sus palabras
soy profesor en una escuela para niñas
de 6 a 15 años Tengo alumnas muy jóvenes
que se acercan a mí me abrazan y me
dicen entre lágrimas arrestaron a mi tía
otras que dicen tengo miedo de que maten
a mis padres la semana pasada las
alumnas se abalanzaron sobre mí
aterrorizadas y me preguntaron Es cierto
que la policía vendrá a ver si
arrancamos las fotos del líder supremo
de nuestros libros
para calmar su ira les dije que prefería
morir antes que dejar que la policía
viniera en nuestra escuela pero el
ambiente es diferente con mis alumnas
mayores de entre 13 y 15 años
tienen una cita fija con chicos de otras
escuelas cercanas a la nuestra y cantan
consignas juntos todos los días después
de la escuela
mis alumnas estaban consternadas por la
noticia de las redadas policiales en las
escuelas la semana pasada las fuerzas de
seguridad atacaron tres escuelas de
nuestra zona niños de tan solo 14 o 15
años fueron detenidos varias niñas y
mujeres iraníes se han convertido en
Mártires de las protestas sus nombres se
han convertido en hashtags e incluso en
gritos de guerra para los que salen a
las calles hadis nayafie 22 años murió
por un disparo mientras se manifestaba
Sarina es maizaieth de 16 años murió
tras ser golpeada con palos por la
policía y nika sacarami de 16 años fue
encontrada muerta tras ser perseguida
por la policía algunas jóvenes afirman a
que fueron agredidas sexualmente tras su
detención están molestas con todo lo que
ocurre en este país y salen a la calle
para mostrar esa rabia mis alumnas me
dicen que lo que más desean es que se
respete su privacidad en el sentido más
amplio tener novio o novia es parte de
la privacidad la de vestir en la calle
también forma parte de su privacidad y
por quien votar para ellas también es
privacidad y es un derecho fundamental
mis alumnas me dijeron Entonces algo que
me rompió el alma dijeron No tenemos
miedo de que nos maten tenemos miedo de
que nos violen antes del fin de semana
como siempre les dije nos vemos la
próxima semana queridas y Ellas me
dijeron si nuestros nombres no se
convierten en un nuevo hashtag como masa
a mini nos vemos la próxima semana
profesora Me impactó profundamente que
jóvenes de 14 y 15 años piensen que
pueden ser asesinadas en los próximos
días y que estén dispuestas a morir si
es necesario
todos vamos
montañas de basura en el medio del
Himalaya este fue el panorama al que se
enfrentaron los alpinistas que se
aventuraron este verano a escalar el k2
el segundo pico más alto del mundo entre
ellos estaba
walitari un alpinista pakistaní de una
región cercana tenía muchas ganas de
escalar el k2 no puedo describir la
emoción que sentí cuando finalmente lo
logré
lo que vi en esa montaña me rompió el
corazón
era como si mi casa estuviera llena de
basura y hubiera que limpiarla
[Música]
y tiene en el campamento 1 hay muchas
carpas viejas que se congelaron bajo la
nieve tal vez 20 o 30
pero cuando hace más calor y el sol
comienza a brillar la nieve y el hielo
comienzan a derretirse
los lugares con los baños o residuos de
comida que están al lado de las carpas
comienzan a derretirse y a oler mal es
insoportable
en las expediciones internacionales
cuando los alpinistas suben a la montaña
siempre tienen prisa por Bajar una vez
que llegan a la cima y a veces se
deshacen de sus cosas y las tiran para
ir más ligeros al bajar
más de 150 alpinistas alcanzaron la
Cumbre este verano esto representa un
aumento de cinco veces en comparación
con una temporada normal y puede
explicarse por el fin de las
restricciones sanitarias pero esta
situación también se debe a un verano
especialmente caluroso que ha hecho a
emerger una cantidad de desechos
enterrados o superior a lo habitual esta
contaminación afecta a los cursos de
agua alimentados por el deshielo y
también repercute no solo en la
población local sino en la diversidad
tiene consecuencias para los propios
alpinistas
entre el campamento 1 y el 2 las cuerdas
están en muy mal estado
por ejemplo cuando escalo lo hago bajo
mi propio riesgo sin saber si las
cuerdas son viejas o nuevas
es un riesgo que tengo que correr
cuando subimos derretimos el hielo para
beber porque Llevamos una pequeña estufa
y podemos servir el agua
es común que los alpinistas tengan
diarrea debido a la calidad del agua
este verano las autoridades pakistanías
organizaron una campaña de limpieza con
los alpinistas se recogieron más de 1600
kilos de residuos en las pendientes del
k2
[Música]
y de esta manera llegamos al final de
los observadores por esta semana
recuerde que todos nuestros contactos
están en la pantalla si quiere contactar
a nuestro equipo envíanos sus fotos y
videos aficionados Quizá el próximo
observador de France 24 sea uno de
ustedes hasta pronto